Valencia is Spain's third-largest city
two million tourists visit the
Mediterranean port annually the Sun
shines year round here the city's
malboro sabita is a popular destination
for visitors and locals alike and the
most traditional among the beach
restaurants here is lappy pika
valenciennes favorite Sunday meal is
paya but here you can order it every day
Lapid pika has been around for more than
a hundred years luck in there was a
Moche most of our guests are regulars
who've been coming here for many years
and they passed the tradition on to
their children their attitude is my
grandmother came here and my father and
now me some customers have been eating
here all their lives today dijo a la
vida the recipes haven't changed in all
that time very popular is pierre de
marisco with pawns and squid a more
exotic variation is arroz negro rice
tinted black with squid ink small shrimp
are added to it but the original local
dish is pyar valencia traditionally
prepared with meat and beans they mostly
use regional products chef Roberto
Blanco buys them at the mercado central
the city's largest market here Roberta
finds everything he needs for his rice
dish
for example fresh poultry and snails
but most important are the typical
Valencian vegetables lima beings called
Gareth on beans grow in the region como
una pelea por que tomar Sabine is a bit
broader it really only use dope I area
there are two kinds fresh like here by
those places it style of fresca or dried
so they keep longer gonna yoloka famous
a tried got off on beans will keep for a
year without a problem sorry got a phone
hey dude Arun on your perfect comment it
back in the kitchen at la pipa car the
original recipe papaya Valencia calls
for fresh lima beans and you also need
chicken and rabbit meat green beans
snails short grain rice tomato puree and
olive oil lip aya is seasoned with
paprika and saffron first Roberto Blanco
cuts the meat into small pieces
it's seared with the vegetables until
the meat is crispy and brown then it's
seasoned deglaze with water then
continue cooking while stirring add the
rice
una LRO yatra it's important to use the
right kind of rice but the water is
important to Valencia has very soft
water and that makes the rice perfect
and not too hard in oboro the Piatt
should simmer for 30 minutes you can
also bake it in an oven at 180 degrees
Celsius which is quicker in both funny
pathan meal out of it Spain has
countless rice recipes food but the pie
area has to come out with the rice
fluffy I'll get together it should be al
dente not sticky and boiled to death it
should be nice and fluffy you must let
the people then the pie a Valencia is
ready with snails chicken and rabbit a
feast that has drawn many famous guests
tulip epica
American writer ernest hemingway used to
come here after watching the bullfights
Spanish star Tina Placido Domingo has
eaten here and Spain's former King Juan
Carlos has been here five or six times
always without prior notice bhumika do
so for a relay was kebab it was funny
because the King like paella with
chicken and rabbit but the Queen wanted
a vegetable pie so that's what we made
for her was I for you and then they
wanted a third one with seafood in the
end the King had to eat the Queen's
paella happy night but he clean the
plate la mujer porque es que no graba
nada and most other guests at la Paix
pika are also reluctant to leave a
morsel on their plates whether they're
pyar is with seafood meat or vegetables